[Music]
welcome to your biscuits I'm link and
I'm Rhett this week at the round table
of dim lighting we are going down the
rabbit hole again once again yes right
here on this white envelope that I'm I
can't read what's in this note card
underneath there is a sealed topic that
will start us on a conversation that
will lead who knows where because we
don't even know where it starts well I
do it's in here but we don't know what
it is somebody pointed out that on
social media you know I'm not much of a
social media guy that's an inside joke
so I'm not even gonna explain it
keep it inside yeah just between you and
me
and just between you and me it's not
that great don't it just happened you
don't want to know it I know you're
frustrated I heard somebody say isn't it
a rabbit trail well that's a good
question and the good answer is no well
what's the difference in rabbit trail a
rabbit hole a rabbit you gotta go down
the rabbit trail to get to a rabbit hole
right waste our time with a rabbit trail
is when you're talking about one thing
and then you get sidetracked about
talking about another thing which is
clearly not what we're gonna be doing
today right so the distinction is I was
a joke that's exactly no no no I thought
you were actually setting up a good
point I know you're not a big big social
media guy but just stay I'm gonna keep
using it just stay with me because it's
becoming an inside joke for all of us
even though you don't know how it
originated now you're in can I just say
that I sent a message to an old friend
asking for his email and I sent it
through a social media service tell the
whole story and his route I don't want
to tell the whole story because I don't
know how it's gonna end yet well no but
you can tell it the context that no
because they don't know if you give any
context at all then they'll know that it
was it's one of those Pete cuz Tim we're
gonna say their name you know what I'm
saying like there's another place that's
happening where their names are being
said so I don't even I'm confused now
just keep going yeah yeah man his
response to can I have your email
address was I'm not a big social media
gap
meaning but I'm just by reaching out on
social media I don't understand he
thinks I'm gonna go one layer deeper
into the social media email is one layer
back further away isn't it yes so a
rabbit trail is when you're talking
about one thing and you get as you
driving you and you get diverted and you
follow it a rabbit hole is deeper into
the same thing Alice in Wonderland
people but it's a direct allusion to
Alice in Wonderland I don't want to say
right yeah follow the White Rabbit I
don't want to say that the rabbit hole
doesn't have a rabbit trail because I do
think the rabbit hole can go anywhere in
other words there might be a fork in the
rabbit hole
then we take and we take a we take a
side and that would be a rabbit hole
trail yeah that's less catchy could call
it a rabbit troll but I don't know if
using because people think it was some
creature writing especially because of
the Alice in Wonderland thing and that's
all alluding to cocaine by the way
you're one of those guys that thinks
that all great children's entertainment
is just comes from people who were high
at that if you play the latest John
Mayer album in sync with Alice in
Wonderland your mind will be fall asleep
I like that no I love it man
but you know soothing I'm John Mary's we
are big me as a John Mayer I'm fans of
the new John Mayer buddies like back
when my body was his Wonderland I liked
him and then oh no that's when he sucked
guys you got to understand John Mayer
came into his own when he went a little
bit country and a little bit rock and
roll now I'm sure you disagree with it
you're objectively wrong I don't know
him personally I don't know anything
about him personally I have a feeling I
like it that if you know stuff about him
personally you might be like what you
shouldn't like John Mayer because of XYZ
reasons because he's an a-hole right but
but you know I don't I don't even know
that all I know is that I love his
latest music and I also see his tweets
and I really like his his uh
philosophical tweets yeah he came up
with an idea about everyone on hold
speaking to one another
like his read most recent viral tweet at
there at the time of this recording
right but then he followed it up with he
got a little he got a little anxious
because he followed it up with a tweet
about how there should be some sort of
light irritant and face wash so you
would know that you had washed your face
in case you forgot and people are like
you should have left this one as a draft
well he had a series of Twitter drafts
and they're referring to that because he
would say you know I'm just gonna I'm
gonna tweet all of my drafts that I
never sent and those were funny because
oh that was well they were
contextualized as I've decided not to
tweet these unless you just found one
you know on its own which is what
happened to me so again I mean I I
mentioned John Mayer being in Zombie
verse yeah and now I'm mentioning him
again and open invitation for John Mayer
to come on here anytime any day of the
week bring your guitar man or just just
don't intimidate us
here's what I want John Mayer to come on
our show but I want him to just play the
mouth guitar okay I can accept X we
could probably hang with him both of us
together
I played the mouth trumpet he plays the
mouth guitar and you just take it in
like watching a tennis match take it in
my mouth
[Laughter]
you're a journey said you said you said
mouth twice and you said you just sit
there and take it in and I was so amount
was ready for my instruments so if
you're not a social media person that
means I've got a code for I don't have
email I'm not much of a social media guy
is that where we were going or do I need
if I need to go back out of this rabbit
trail so we can talk about the rabbit
hole again the rabbit hole can be
whatever we wanted to be man but we're
gonna stick with rabbit hole cuz that's
what we started with might I just say
that I'm I'm very full right now I'm on
a sugar high at the time of recording
this I am still thirsty right just say
right now
no I wanna say at the time of this
recording because I like to put
historical markers on things that's what
I appreciate what people do that is that
is that that coin you've been placed
the studio yeah it's like what's that
call me the Historical Marker that's a
stupid joke thank you for going along
with it thank you for laughing I'm still
39 I'll be 40 tomorrow and Link and I
also went I will not I was ceased
talking to you and July to turn 40 you
got a while linking out to our steak
dinner that we promised that we would do
in the last chapter of the book of
mythicality stop and celebrate we said
we would stop and celebrate when we
finished the book we would go have a
steak dinner there would be hollandaise
an interesting thing is is when we sat
down that we told the waiter oh we're
gonna need some hollandaise and he said
there will be hollandaise which is
exactly what we wrote in the book did we
write it I think that may have edited
that out I think it's I think it said
there will be Han days but then when you
read it earlier today he didn't say
there will be hollandaise we edited it
out but we did talk about how there
would be no hollandaise spilled on the
book but then you purposely spilt
hollandaise on the book on your own face
it looked like I was eating it but then
so oh and the guy said because it was my
birthday first of all thanks for telling
that was my birthday they printed my
name on the menu no they do that for all
the menus if you go to Morton's
Steakhouse in Burbank but it said have
any time years it says happy birthday
Rekha's odds are a retz gonna stroll in
and it's gonna be his birthday and the
guy said but giving it a birthday would
you like a dessert and of course I never
say no to that I mean I'm not a big
social media guy but I think I'm a big
dessert guy so I had the key lime pie
link had a bite of it and said that it
was too tart for him she's not
surprising at all it was it was better
than lemon pie which is horrible yeah I
actually like that as well so it's not I
didn't say anything with that statement
in then I left no historical marker on
that statement and then I got here to
the office and they had a cake for me
because it's my birthday which I should
have I should have thought about cuz if
now we're traveling tomorrow well there
was a general slack this morning that
also said hey guys 3:30 we're all gonna
celebrate Darren's birthday and rets
birthday a day early get ready for that
but don't eat any key lime pie
stakeout I'm so selfless that those kind
of statements just I forgot it's my
birthday tomorrow
I don't think about myself at all no so
I totally agree with them so when when I
saw everybody gathered and you know it
took it took a few moments for me to
realize that I was even a part of it
that it was a yes the assembly was at
least half for me but I saw the wood
cake you didn't knew that oh my no cake
I didn't even get close to it I took a
picture of it put it on my I'm not a big
social media guy but I did put it on my
Instagram
after a buddy after invited that key
lime pie I couldn't go near your wood
cake I didn't even get to see it but I
ate it but it was pure indulgence I mean
I was in the back of the crowd I was
that guy moping back there thinking
about when it was gonna be my birthday
but the the key lime pie alone was pure
indulgent indulgence but then the second
dessert on top of it the ridiculous by
the way my wife is the one that advised
them on this made out of wood no I had a
wood top but it was just let me see he
was a decoration it just looked like a
tree was it edible or is it that fondant
stuff that losers put on cakes when they
want to cover the fact that it doesn't
taste good I don't think that you
understand it looked like this it looked
like Oh a tree had been cut it's like a
cross section of a tree would you what
and it had a wood joke would you guess
Rhett's forty that is hilarious and then
it was a red velvet cake and and cream
cheese icing and then ice cream cake
oh no they didn't they're so good it's
your favorite it is I wonder how they
knew that I wonder who they asked well
that's what I started with when I said
my wife is the one know them I was
trying to take credit for it
I had no questioning in it no part in it
so anyway I don't even see it all that
to be said all that to say that I could
fall asleep at any moment when I come
down off the sugar high if I get quiet
or introspective don't worry about me
I'm about to turn 40 you typically get
introspective when you're dozing off I'm
saying when I get quiet you can just
assume that I'm being introspective put
it back on the timer so we'll know how
long we have to owe it all sellout the
inside information torture these people
we time these things guys
we know that we're not talking for too
short or too long my head I'm tired too
I'm sorry I mean it contagious I didn't
mean any of the cake yeah I just called
you Dan but it's okay Charlie you've got
what a weird podcast already you've got
I which is technically your name by the
way so it wasn't even weird well calling
you Dan it's kind of odd yeah she called
you run from now on I want to call you
Dan that's fine let's get ready to go
down this rabbit hole but first let's
take a moment to shout out our sponsors
which is us the video version is podcast
we sponsor ourselves an audio version
you get we get other sponsors which may
or may not be more legitimate than us
sponsoring ourselves can you hold that
link I don't know how sad this is but
I'm pretty proud of this shirt it's got
my face on it there's a first grader and
rets face on her the first grader this
is when we met you can buy this shirt
now mystical dot store says Renton link
established
oh nine oh four eighty four the reason
that it's 904 is because some one of you
guys did some research and went back and
somehow looked up the the historical
records and determined that that was the
first day of school for Harnett County
Schools for Boys Creek School in 1984
September 4th which seems about right to
me this is the well official shirt which
if you are a partaker of the book of
mythicality if not why not
this is in the get lost chapter this is
the only this is an animal that will be
constructed using CRISPR in the future
we talk all about this animal under our
supervision this is an animal that is
incapable of getting lost because it has
all the different characteristics of
animals that can not get lost in one
animal mythical dot store support
internat Ament you can get this your
biscuits jar and if you put your ear up
to it you can hear us talking yeah we
ready to open this up mm-hmm all right
brace yourself kids we're going down the
rabbit hole
bend over rabbit coming in is this oh
gosh is this still a question it's not
how it works it's a place where a rabbit
lives prompt was what are you thinking
about right now
okay so it could be anything Helen
Hansen asks what did my dog name me oh
now I got a dog what did my dog name me
it's in my lab right now she just sits
there
my dog listen this is this is for the
audio people just she's sniffing the mic
she shouldn't if she just she licked the
inside of my mouth I didn't think I'd
ever become that guy but it's her yeah
but I thought that you Neal actually you
didn't like the dog licking on the face
I don't like it but I secretly feel
loved by it
I spent laughs lens man we make out with
Barbara all the time it's so gross it's
so gross she's bored of this thing but
you can look at her face sometimes
she'll be looking at me and I'm like
what are you thinking I'm called no I
mean like what are you thinking but I've
never thought I wonder what she calls me
but didn't the movie up answer this
question because of the device yeah man
that was a Pixar movie that was
make-believe you know I've made out with
your dog that's like in secret no I mean
like today you want to do it right now
I'll let her lick my face I don't care
well do you want to make out with my dog
I don't give tongue back that's what
you're asking
but I accept Tong from dogs listen got
into the mouth Dan do not ever make out
with my dog unless I'm watching again
how weird do you want to make this you
want I'm just saying I die first of all
people are like it's gross and it's
dirty but dogs used to lick
back when they did things like her
beaches on people I know oh you mean
humans wounds yeah you talking about
historically when someone would get hurt
they would they'd put a dog on the wound
to lick it I seem to think that that
could be the case again we're not
allowed to look anything up until the
end of the podcast so no internet
references because well I I don't know
that was a rule I know it but last time
it worked so well okay
because if a dog has a wound they lick
it hints you know the same a dog licks
its wounds I don't I think that also a
dog returns to its own vomit which is
also true and should make me not want to
make out with them but what I'm saying
is that the dog wants the dog wants to
lick my face it is a natural thing that
the dog wants to do that's because the
smells coming out of it or food like
well that may be part of it but it's
also as I've been told a form of the dog
is kind of submitting to you it's
looking you're licking your face so the
dog is like that's what they would do to
your like the pack leader you know all
the humans can be in the family can the
dog is subordinate to all the humans
right when I go up to Jade's food she
backs away like she literally like backs
away like tail first in submission and
sometimes I'm like filling her bowl with
food and then when I leave she'll come
back up and start to eat it but she
submits to my authority to eat the food
first which on in desperate situations I
do partake and then she'll come back in
so yeah she definitely knows that that
I'm in charge but that doesn't keep her
from sometimes snapping cuz she's not
you even at me yeah
this Jade ever do like like in the bed
like if she gets comfortable anywhere
not just in the bed but she does sleep
in the bed with me and Kristi
most of the time I would say 8 out of 10
nights and the other two nights she
might sleep with one of the other kids
if she gets in in that nestled in this a
perfect spot that she wants to be in
and then if it's like well I want to be
in that spot she what she gets she gets
mad it's like that's exactly the noise
she does she have a a mad play mode
because like what Barbara will do is I
can get Barbara so worked up well she's
just growling and going nuts and she
looks like a rabid vicious dog by the
way there's an Ellen growling but she's
she is playing with me mm-hmm
yeah like she she bites me but it's
super soft and like it's all part of a
game like she's she looks crazy she's
making crazy noises but we're just
playing and I'm like like kind of like
poking her in the stomach and stuff and
she and are you making growling noises
too oh yeah oh yeah but she would never
actually bite me and then as soon as I
like stop she knows okay where that's
that kind of playtime is over now but
she's not actually mad my I feel like
Jade would if Jay get got to that point
Jay would be actually biting well with
Barbara like when we bring them both to
the office they do it they do it
together they like they're like
intensely growling and like at each
other's throats
literally and Barbara I mean like a
third the size of well a third bigger
one-third bigger than Jade but she's
more submissive like she'll roll over
yeah put her because she's I don't know
it's interesting why that's the dynamic
Jade is much more just persnickety I
think it's just the breed breed type
thing but they both were like not each
other's necks which is the kill zone but
they're just plain because no one has
been killed [ __ ]
she does that occasionally with me but
we don't play that way that often I
don't she's more like Vinnie I mean Jade
is much more like a cat like she just
wants to lay in a spot and then
occasionally I'll open the front door
and she'll dart out onto the front lawn
and then she'll just run around in
circles and it's just like getting out
all this like tension and then she'll
like sniff something and then she'll pee
and then she'll dart back in the house
and she'll find a spot and she'll growl
if you try to move her Barbara that's
our life
just wants to be on you whoever you are
there's have to be a family member it
could be somebody who just came over
yeah like if you lay down she comes up
she gets on top of you and puts her feet
one foot on each side of your face and
then just starts licking your face and
then when she stops looking your face
she just puts her head on your face
she's very sweet
jade is not and that's where she wants
in the morning like she sleeps at the
foot of the bed in the bed yes in the
bed under the covers no and Dave asleep
under the as soon as you like
you like you wake up and kind of like
roll over and she knows Oh humans awake
and next thing you know she's just she's
in that position I know you've talked
about this before and you talked about
how you would do your stretches first on
you and it made me cry
remember I'll try to make you cry don't
make me cry again we've already talked
about this but the problem with Jade
that we're having is we're coming to
grips with the fact that we didn't know
this but as a breed was about to say
warmer honors but she's not a Weimaraner
she's not anything close to that
what is she a Wienerschnitzel she's a
Datsun a Datsun minute Jetson she's a
long-haired miniature Datsun mixed with
a poppy on of course the person we
adopted her from lied about what she was
and says she was purebred same thing for
us and I think we talked about that too
but what what she what we discovered is
that the Datsun part of her DNA dictates
that she is very difficult to housebreak
or house-trained or whatever you call it
potty break use the bathroom outside
they're notorious for this and of course
you know we we we write about this in
the book about how how we pick Jade and
the mistakes we made
I don't regret picking Jade I mean all
of this is in the chapter the book so
I'd rather not rehash that I want to
reward those of you who are gonna read
that but as a side product of how we
went about picking the dog erroneously I
never knew that oh this is a big deal
they like to they like to sneak away in
pee and poop other places it is a daily
battle
and it will be with us the rest of her
life to keep her from peeing and pooping
in other places and it drives me nuts
but why don't you just embrace it I love
her so much
brace it what do you mean just let pee
and poop be every lots of people do that
I can't be that person so I will I will
just I'll go into a frenzy of trying to
get it up now I like it when she poops
in the house that's how bad it's gotten
what I would prefer like like if I you
know if we could have a talk I'm looking
at it right now I'm like Jayde I don't
care if you poop in the house just lay a
log anywhere you want they're pretty
self-contained they're pretty dry after
a few seconds I can just reach down pick
it up throw it in the toilet and flush
it like a human turd but it's the pee
that's the problem
I mean you leave a little circle here
you leave a little circle there and once
you've left a circle I understand that
you're compelled to then leave a circle
on top of the circle you're making Venn
diagrams on all of our rugs and it's
unacceptable she doesn't look like she
cares it's frickin unacceptable and we
can't get it up she doesn't look ashamed
at all she looks mildly annoyed with you
that look at me look at me look at me
now Jade Jade Jade listen that rug that
we have in our bedroom it's like a sheet
don't guess Lisa missing she's some
missing - you don't make out with my
face when I'm reprimanding you you can
make out with me you want me telling me
she looks sad okay play-by-play rets
coming over to get don't kiss the
Mustang I don't care I like it she just
licked the inside of my mouth and then
she licked your mustache self-cleaning
it she she took care of it in a few
seconds before it came to me Jade I love
you no matter what but it annoys me when
you pee in the house but you just said
you're gonna have to deal with I just
say get a yellow yellow carpet and just
a yellow carpet with very varying colors
of yellow in like a Venn diagram type
pattern calico yellow carpet be like I
don't know where she pees somewhere
you know what everywhere just get a
white carpet she'll make that but let's
dig into this question what did my dog
named eat now interestingly the question
behind the question is what's going on
inside of a dog's brain right
and like I when I was holding up Jade
for that you know the thing I was doing
the bit right look she looks you said
she looked you you personified her
reaction in that moment yeah but she's
not annoyed because I don't believe that
they I mean they can be annoyed but it
isn't the same type of type of annoyance
that if she's annoyed it wouldn't
manifest itself on her face because dogs
have not evolved to a place where
they're reading the facial expressions
of each other for it that's not how they
communicate humans on the other hand our
faces communicate very specific things
to each other right but and monkeys
we're - well yeah but we're taking those
facial expressions and we're projecting
them on to the dog whereas the dog does
not have any point of reference for
understanding other dogs facial
expressions so it doesn't under so
interesting couple of things I do think
apply apply here yeah
domesticated dogs again we can't look
anything up on the internet so this is
like a serious paraphrase but
domesticated dogs have actually meaning
this is BS no it's not BS I'm saying
that it's a paraphrase so I'm not gonna
get it exactly right but domesticated
dogs as in Jay Barbara dogs that have
been bred by humans one of the things
that separates them from wolves is their
ability to make and maintain eye contact
with humans and I think I'm not wrong in
saying this that they may be I mean
obviously they they're the only
non-primate mammals that are capable of
that type of connection with a with a
person and then when they don't make eye
contact that is a sign of submission I
think I've I've I've heard Cesar say
that
I'm paraphrasing of course right boy
what I'm saying is they don't make eye
contact with each other hmm
they don't make eye contact with each
other they make eye contact with humans
they make nose too but kind they have no
reason there they're relying on a lot of
different things mostly smell yeah they
may be like overall body language or
something but they're not and obviously
you know they hear things and growling
and that kind of thing and biting and
cannot say the word growl can you
growling but that doesn't they don't
look at each other and think oh he has a
mean look on his face in his eyes they
don't they don't talk to each other in
that way it's funny because last night
we were in bed and Christi goes Jay just
seems depressed lately now I think a dog
can be depressed I certainly I know that
to be true but you're not gonna find
light on the dog you're just not gonna
look at the dog's face and know that
because she looks sad but sometimes if
her if her nose is down and she's
looking up it's just just the cheer
shape of her face makes her look sad and
that's why that's what I love about it
sometimes you'll see a dog that's
smiling yeah that's but Barbara does
this thing where that's like singing a
jack-o'-lanterns happy she's got all
this hair right around her she's
basically got it like a beard and she
will lie down on the bed and then like
the covers will kind of push this up and
she'll turn to me and she's got this her
hair is going like this and it looks
like a giant smile but she's not smiling
even when the dog smiles and you see the
corners of it it doesn't again they
haven't
there's nothing genetically happening
that is contributing to a smile that
you're just totally perceiving that but
that doesn't mean there can't be some
like a you know it's body language like
this position to know that the dog is
depressed like when I last night when I
got home and started going in the front
door I heard her barking around the side
where the trash cans are where she is
supposed to pooping pee and so I snuck
around there and I went through the gate
and I just busted through the gate I
just went nuts and she it she freaked
out what reason to freak her out
she freaked out because it was kind of
dark over there and she's like running
around on this is you realize this is
counterproductive to trying to get her
to go outside and relax and well the
bathroom she's finally in though in the
one space she may have been a ready to
release it
are you like no no no all she hears is
that no this is not supposed to happen
so you just set yourself back months mmm
that's a good point don't do that again
that is a good point so anyway she's
freaking out and then I'm like hey it's
me and then she realized it was me and
like the tail went up and started
wagging and she comes up to me and she
does this dance on her hind legs like
one of those dogs that you like have to
like put in the circus for years you
don't have to put them in the circus
well that you have to be in the circus
for years to learn how to do that I mean
it is this it is a skill to enslave a
dog to that level my dog doesn't
naturally I'm pretty proud of that and
but I was interpreting her body language
as acceptance unacceptable I mean
unconditional love and thorough
acceptance in relief I wasn't a bear or
a trash monster and so she went inside
and pooped she she did to reward you
yeah I I do not I I don't punish her for
if I don't catch her in the act
we don't punish her we've read
everything we need to read about how to
deal with it and I don't want to get
into the potty training but I only use
positive reinforcement yeah yeah so I
you know we do the same thing we do not
not convinced that it works we do not we
do not shame or in any way abuse you do
the most valuable member of our family
just scared you just scare the dog well
she just obscene it was a prank she
knows I mean she was like so relieved
just in the way that you are when you
watch a horror movie another fact that
we can set on the table to see if this
is gonna help us get to this answer is
there was a another recent study where
they put dogs into
cat scan machines MRI no that's an MRI
this would be like a brain scan well
true so they basically did a scan of the
dog's brain that Italy had to train dogs
to be able to lie still inside of a cat
scan machine and not be freaked out by
the noise and that was a feat in and of
itself there's got to be a cat dogs can
joke somewhere in there yep you take
some time to figure that out I'll be
thinking about and the what they
discovered well I'm gonna I'm gonna - so
um I don't know if you heard me talk
about those that you read it but they
compared rewarding an animal a dog with
food mm-hmm or rewarding a dog with
praise from a person its owner and how
do you think the dog what do you think
the difference is which is what's a
stronger motivator for dog's food
rewarding with food or rewarding with
praise I think the the heart of a dog
has a much greater capacity than the
stomach of a dog so I think the biggest
factor is is the dog hungry or not so
you did a little flipper Rooney on that
you started to say one thing and then
you came to the opposite conclusion
no on purpose no definitely not the
heart of a dog is much bigger than the
stomach of a dog and then you said so it
was the food which is the analysis I'm
saying the food the food is the limiting
factor I didn't that was not my answer
okay that was my rationale to give my
answer which I've yet to give okay give
your answer which is praise okay well it
turns out now III was thinking when I
started to read this I was thinking
about Barbara always thinking about
Barbara does she love food a praise so
she loves food like she loves praise but
if I have if it's been established that
I have treats I can get you think you
got Jay dancing like a circus dog I can
get Barbara to drive a
and golf cart she'd have to go out you
get her to go purchase a golf cart I had
her then drive it back no I had her
caddy an entire round of golf at Hilton
Head hilton head they don't allow you to
have flashy billboards it's a really
classy but you can have dog you can have
dog caddies it was a man that's got tat
doggie caddy let me see it somewhere in
there the first the first nine holes I
had to tell her which club I needed
right right and then she would bring it
and but you'd give her a treat we can
get when you told her head club keep
giving her treats the second nine holes
she measured the distance and had the
club waiting and did you have to still
give treats yes right the moment that I
run out of treats she's swimming on a
pond on the back nine back nine hole 15
par five dogleg left got a nice seven
mile-per-hour mile per mile per hour
left the right wind so I'm like I'm
gonna play a little draw but it's gonna
sort of the draw will be taken off
because of the left-to-right wind right
oldest land nice meal no that's out of
that sand trap Barbour was a complete
agreement with this yeah but she says
would that wind you may want to use a
3-wood instead of a driver so I went
with the 3-wood but then I ran out of
treats mmm and then I didn't know
whether or not I should go for the green
on the second shot or I should lay up
and where was she by that point because
I didn't have any food he was completely
acting like a dog she was licking
herself she was just finding different
weird stuff
she was humping things left and right
she doesn't even have a penis and she
still humping just she's seen other dogs
hump right really going deep with this
one so what did you what club did you
choose and what happened I went for it I
ever landed in the water you blew it
yeah I should have laid up no you should
have brought more treats yeah yeah I
don't double bogeyed basically out the
rest of the back nine now she is she
interested in giving it a swing no she's
just interesting she giving me advice
she knows her role yeah so as I was
saying very motivated but by food did
you ever praise her when
ran out of treats were you like good
advice girl yeah it doesn't work that's
my point she does not respond she she
actually so she poops outside and you
know we actually had a trainer come you
remember this we I paid to have this
woman show up once a week for a couple
of months mm-hmm to like it was one of
those things where it's just like
everything she told me I was like that
seems so obvious but the fact that
you're here telling me this makes it
more likely that we'll actually enact
something you know did you pay her in
treats by the way no she insisted on
cash Hey and and a lot of it man you
know Southern California dog trainers
that's like a doctor in North Carolina
you sure you got a prenup so Barbara is
so attuned to the food that she comes in
after pooping and she and if I'm a good
girl she like she's got this look on her
face like she's looking at my hands and
she's like trying to get an angle on my
hands cuz she's just like if you don't
have a treat I don't care we're talking
about a dog that loves people yeah so
much so anyway but she loves that treat
that was the anecdotal you know evidence
that I was bringing to this particular
study so when I actually heard was this
a web survey I can't remember no it was
a scientific this wasn't like one of
those like click here to decide which
Harry Potter character typically they
don't have to use the action they
wouldn't actually use a cat scanning
machine for a web survey I remember now
this was doctors and scientists this is
a study you read so anyway you stole my
thunder a little bit because you guessed
praise but it's actually there even
which is I think for the average person
that was a surprise that dogs would
respond to praise just as much as they
respond to food because a lot of time
because I think most people are just
like well my dog only loves me because I
am the one that feeds it and I think a
lot of you would say that about cats and
that may be true about cats I don't know
nothing about cats but I'm not gonna
make any statements podcasts other than
I do
like them hate him but I do know that a
lot of people are like cats he would eat
you if they could
right might be true under their jaw but
unhinge like a boa but there are
definitely cases of imagine coming home
and seeing it an unhinged jaw of your
house cat wrapped around I don't know a
toddler
oh gosh link that'd be scary dream about
that tonight I'm not gonna dream about
that I'm gonna do everything I can to
wipe that image from my brain for the
rest of the day fine a snake a cat but
there are occasions eNOS name there are
cases of dogs hole taking care of their
owners after they die so well there's
not much take care of no like staying by
like first of all there's cases of dogs
sentinel taking care of a person who's
sick and can't get up yeah like bringing
them things but there's also cases of
dogs staying next to their owner that
has died until someone comes to help and
these dogs are deprived of water and
food but they don't start eating the
person I'm no scientist but I do believe
a cat would eat a person you know I have
to think about cats but it turns out
that it is evenly nicknamed they're
nodding but you're at you are a dog
person you own a dog Cielo won't care
but also Bacchus no no but I think that
scientifically I would wouldn't you say
that cats are have been less
domesticated than dogs I mean a cat if
you have a cat with the exception of
maybe just a few breeds you don't have
to keep it inside I mean like if you
just let it go off it'll bring birds and
fish and squirrels but if I let Barbara
outside Barbara would be eaten within
the first 12 hours by some other animal
she's not and they're all there are
breeds of dogs that would bring back all
types of animals - but I'm saying there
are certain breeds you're saying more
cats are more likely as a whole to be
like savage hunters you have to get a
certain breed of dog to make that happen
and also
cats don't respond nearly as much
to humans and to anything you don't like
you don't have cats like I'm sure there
are people who do cat tricks like yeah
sitting and doing but they can't do
nearly what dogs do because the
connection is not nearly as great in
dogs and cats don't come up to you and
look do you have any food you have any
food you all over you
they just doesn't happen some people
prefer that that's fine I'm sure there
are cats I'm sure we'll get comp a dog
like my cat Louis getting really nervous
about taking a hard line on cats how did
you even get into cats man
man screw cat I just want to talk about
really hard line on cats again screw us
talking about cats cuz we're stew us
talk about dogs so dog we ain't got no
business talking about cats
so basically I've said all this to get
to two points that I want to consider so
we can answer this question definitively
scientifically holistically again
permanently you've got the fact that
they can make eye contact with people so
there's a connection with people but
also that they respond to praise from
their human owners now I do acknowledge
that there are some people who are
uncomfortable with that word but I you
gotta get in you know human owners you
got to suggest it you got to come up
with something if you're gonna have a
problem with using the turn owner for
someone who takes care of a dog you you
got a case not friend is it it's not mom
you got to come up with something before
you start tearing something down as the
long held tradition you got to have
something you got to prepare with
something okay that's my note for the
people who don't want to be called
owners of dogs about fur pain there's
there's actually a whole movement of
people who don't believe for pinion
that's good for pinion I like that a lot
there you go so get off it for pain you
okay yeah take it back well but you were
pretty irate you don't even movie that
worked up a lot of well there are people
who don't believe that we should have
pets at all they think the whole
industry of having pets is wrong they
think that oh gosh I'm getting scared
they think having pets and I live in
California you know to a couple years
now we gonna be that liberal is won't be
relinquished in Jade to the wild we're
gonna spend the next three years
training Jade and Barbara to live on
their own as fully fully realized humans
but but what will happen not first of
all so I cannot go on record they're
gonna be pulling this out I do believe
if I let Barbara out at Hilton Head
she'll just get a job as a caddy and
she'll take care of herself but anywhere
other than Hilton Head because they
don't allow dogs to caddy anywhere else
as far as I know what about Boca Raton I
haven't been there she could do it there
I don't know she's too humid
everything's pink in Boca Raton but
assuming that she doesn't get a job as a
caddy I think she's gonna eat get eaten
by a coyote oh you know certainly and so
I I feel like I'm giving Barbara her
best life now sometimes sometimes I call
Joel Osteen man and I'm like Joel so I'd
be like real liberal are we quoting Joel
see I don't know what's happening dojo
first of all Joel I know you're a
listener Joel what you need to do your
next book needs to be give your dog its
best life now it could be a
collaboration with Caesar for pain yin
and then we introduced a term for pain
yin yeah well that's copyrighted we took
care of that before this came out so
anyway where we going with this oh man
did we just hit the end of a rabbit no
no no no no no no we got to do is back
up and go to the main crevice of the
hole I guess I took a rabbit trail off
of the rabbit hole when I started
getting all the people who don't believe
that we should own animals as pets okay
maybe that's a different rabbit hole
first okay I'll say this to get back to
what does Jade call me what does Barbara
call you in their own mind on the
ownership tip I mean I do think that
Jade you know yep they're pack animals
you're either you're either the alpha or
your or your submissive and maybe
there's some for painting relationships
where the where the animal where the dog
is the Alpha and the relationship with
the human and they you know you baby you
do everything that the dog wants and
your life revolves around the dog and
hey Who am I to judge vocally on this
podcast but I have a loophole in the for
opinion thing though I'm just saying my
McCanless
cat musculus cat hairless cats man sorry
let me finish my point before you start
bringing man that's just the organs
exposed in the cat
well that's gross all the rage have you
seen on the Westside have you seen the
skinless cats the ladies are carrying
around in the purses dan basically just
a face in organs fits in your purse you
have to have a circus it's like a
biology demonstration there's a doctor
in West Hollywood that you go to if any
anatomical and he breeds it but it has
to be the cat has to be taken out of
this bag and put into your purse that's
that's how it is it like you have to
reinforce it like I said skinless it's
hairless so like hairless cats are can't
be for opinions they don't have any then
I mean fur you know there are some
hairless dogs too right
it's hairless breed hairless cats are
cats too man I know that but are they
ferp anyons we'll come back to that the
name does discriminate against hairless
cats and skinless cats for that matter
mm-hmm I mean I just pictured like a
bunch of chicken wire wrapped around a
cat it's organs yeah that's bad too bad
mental picture but continue your point
oh you want to replace that mental
picture with a cat eating a toddler go
back to that one man that CATSA jaw just
really gets unhinged I never thought I
could get around the head of that
big-headed toddler we're not talking
about this anymore no you are but I'm
just I'm kind of letting it die well the
point that I was making was in every
Wolf Pack there's an alpha and then
there's the others so the dog wants you
to be the Alpha yeah I mean they'll fall
in line I mean it's just it's how they
work
it's how they would work in the wild you
know sometimes they write they want to
be the Alpha if you don't that's easier
says yes one of the big problems sure
when you don't when you're not the Alpha
they see themselves that they off but
then things get out of hand real fast
and you got to fix that and it's tough
to come back from that Caesar can do it
with the help of Joel Osteen I think
that my dog names me alpha I think my
name to Jade is alpha okay is that your
answer right now it is I think I have
the real answer what I don't like what
your record implied about my answer oh I
have another answer I have an
alternative answer okay yes now it has
been documented as well that dogs
obviously dogs understand their own
names and this can be demonstrated one
of the most entertaining ways I've ever
seen it demonstrated is there's a
YouTube video of a pack of dogs at the
bottom of a stairs
oh no I thought you I'll remind you the
other one but go ahead and it's it's
like a bunch of the same breed of dogs
Border Collies or something and there's
literally like eight to ten dogs and
they're all standing at the bottom of
the stairs and they all want to come
upstairs and then the owner calls them
each by name and they one by one and
it's like Donner Blitzen like as she
calls the name huh we tell my Santa they
one by one they know their names so well
and they would and I enter to say that
they can look at the other one that's
good that didn't happen in the video as
far I haven't watched it for that reason
but in other words they recognized you
can rewatch it for that reason and I'm
sure there are cases of dogs knowing
that oh she just said Donner that's my
buddy here there's actually another
video going around to two dogs and
they're trying to get the dog with one
dog to sit and the older dog puts his
paw on the back of the other dog and
makes him sit so they'll get a treat cuz
he cuz he knows what's going on he's
like she's telling you to sit just sit
so we can both get a treat so they can
definitely recognize human language but
the problem is is what but can i and
what about the video first of well what
about the video where
you were showing me this one where the
person would say something and then the
dog would run over and put its face in a
hole yeah yeah yeah what it wasn't a
hole was it well a lot is the word a lot
of this is is it I follow him on
instagram zat Tony Baker is that his
name
comedian and he's he's kind of known
he's a stand-up comedian but he's known
for doing these voiceovers of these
animal videos that's why I started
following him he does a bunch of them if
any and so a lot of these kind of come
through his feet and one of them is this
a little like Pomeranian that when you
bring out the toe clippers like a
toenail clippers a dog will go into like
did he make the video or did he risk the
video and then he voiced it over right
he doesn't make any other videos yeah
but he this little Pomeranian goes into
a house but it will go into whatever is
it can go and it keeps getting smaller
as the closest the close once you hold
up the toenail clippers it goes to the
closest thing that it can hide in it'll
get in a bag
it'll get like int but then by the end
it's like a cup and it's just like
sticking its nose into the cup yeah like
that way that is hiding like a like a
toddler sticking its face into a like a
cat's mouth missile areas that's a great
video to watch but that doesn't really
support any of the points that I'm
making right now
but but it's funny though and my
question is when do you have time to
watch these videos like you showed me
the one and it was hilarious and like
never since then have I been like I'm
not a big social media guy or anything I
do I do I do have an Instagram account
that I go on and I follow people and so
it comes up in the feet and I watch it
like I do have a problem though because
I'll get into I'll just you know I I do
the thing where Twitter Instagram
newsfeed whatever and I like go through
them a couple of times before I go to
bed then I go through them again when I
wake up it's bad I'm addicted to my
phone and it's not good for a while
there I didn't have my phone next to me
I was putting it in the bathroom that
lasted a couple weeks that's another
conversation but let me tell me what you
thought
Barbara calls you well that's what I'm
getting to
so we know that dogs
can recognize names and we also know
that dogs have the ability to vocalize
things they have some sort of language
right now but that's just mockery that
poor that's just mimicry at that point
oh no but they don't know what they're
doing at that point they're doing
something I don't know how you get a dog
to do that sure they could do that in
Hilton Head but but what happens with it
so we talked about this before you know
how when a wolf or a dog but this has
been documented more with wolves okay
when they Hal if you'll notice sometimes
you'll play like a musical instrument or
you play music or you'll make your own
howling noise mm-hmm and a dog will
begin to howl and the dog never hits the
same note as you and it's not because
dogs can't sing but it's been documented
that they actually purposely hit
different frequencies so a bunch of
wolves howling together they don't all
hit the same note they hit and it's not
harmonics they don't hit harmonies but
they almost hit like purposely dissonant
different notes as their own sound
signature again yeah so they so they had
the ability to do pretty complex
vocalizations but they're I don't
believe that there's it's been
documented that they have names for each
other now I realize I'm taking the
scientific approach here but they have
the ability whales do but oh yeah Oh
whales do dolphins do in the naming
themselves as babies yeah right they
which is an interesting which which
sounds like a very Southern California
think that'll start happening with kids
you know let's let the children name
themselves so then all kids will be
named ah yeah exactly
it'll be chaos which is why dolphin
society is such a mess right now right
they really got someone needs to step in
right yeah to free-spirited does
dolphins are too free-spirited anymore
structure you know they got to have
something I got to have a leader to get
have a strong leader but they won't
everybody they want the kids to be in
charge and that's where they're having
so many troubles right if you want to
play golf you got to deal with a runoff
got it so I think the definitive answer
to this unfortunately is that your dog
cannot name you but your dog can
recognize your name and if it's a smart
dog it will recognize your name so in
other words I'm sure we could find a
YouTube video of this let's say there's
a family there standing there and you'd
say Barbara go to go to link Barbara go
to read and Barbara if Barbara was
trying I've seen this video and it is a
dog who is told to get a specific toy
exactly and it's a basket full of toys
and then they're like gray wolf
go get the hambone bring back to hambone
gray wolf
go get the creepy clown face that
squeaks but no longer squeaks because
you damaged it there you go it goes and
gets the creepy clown face that squeaks
but no longer squeaks because he damaged
it I've seen this video so I think
you're onto something but the real
question is Tony Baker didn't voice it
over will a dog at some point be able to
like cuz the real question is is the dog
in its own mind in like processing
something that could be the equivalent
of a name when it thinks of you and I
would and I would think that the number
one identifier that a dog uses with a
person is smell wouldn't you think when
you think that it's a smell signature no
cuz I walked through my front door and
then there's a vestibule a lobby if you
will to my home and then there's another
vegetable there's another door double
door that's mostly glass which so
basically when I walk in my front door
this is why you never respond when I
come to your house and knock on the door
I ring the doorbell because a the
doorbell does not work even though you
insisted it does and B I not but I'm
knocking on the house out of the
vegetable right you need to you need to
have access but you've a lot to the
inner sanctum you've locked I've not
even you
so yeah so then you don't and then I
text you I'm here I'm here and in seven
minutes of pass and I'm just don't have
reception I'm just to doofus on them
yeah even though you say well I've got
no no I got reception I have a special
antenna that we that we that we built
that we bought that gives us perfect
reception well that's not working either
ma'am so many times I've looked like a
strange robber on your doorstep seven to
ten minutes just sitting there trying to
pick my way in and things shall just go
around the back one time I did go around
the back you scared J when she was
trying to poop yeah you set me back a
couple of months so anyway when I come
home and I'm standing in my vestibule
it's basically like I'm in my own I'm an
exhibit in the zoo you can see I can see
the whole rest of the house cuz the the
double doors are almost all glass Jade
can also see me and she goes ape crap
for me what can I say
but I'm not fabulous but she does not
smell me yet oh she probably does smell
you she probably does smell you well I
will say this probably also sees you she
record she woke us up barking the other
morning and she's going nuts and I went
out second floor I went out on the
balcony and looked down well actually I
don't know why I sitting me cuz it
wasn't me it was Christie oh I think we
just learned something about I was
making Christie story my own I don't
know why you have a tendency to do this
no I was I was in the vestibule so I was
trying to tell that story but I got
sidetracked this is Christie story I'm
not gonna commandeer it but she did tell
me in such a vivid fashion that I felt
like I experienced it and she did take a
video so she goes out there and there's
a bear there's a bear down there in our
backyard
yeah cuz we back up to some woods and
like there's one bear that turns over a
trash can and like goes all around well
there was just one window open and Jade
smell smelled the bear because I she I
don't think we heard the bear the bear
was very quiet yeah bears are quiet I
think she could smell me through the
vestibule but you don't smell as strong
as a bear but on it so what's your point
if you're right about that which I
didn't mean to support you but I guess I
did
then your point is your dog names you
with a smell not even though I do agree
that we've made a lot of progress in
believing that they do know the names of
their owner if they're as smart as that
dog that can pull out the ham bone so
dogs are certainly capable of knowing
their owners names so if I'm sitting
next to Jade and then Christie's like
links it she'll reach over and like put
a paw on my butt
well that is the question is many times
as it's like Barbara also obviously in
je ously nose like they are members of
the family and like barber knows that
like okay there's the there's the big
one that's me and then there's the one
with long hair that's Jesse and then
you've got the kids you've got she's
like okay Shepherds the one that messes
with me and kind of annoys me and gets
my bark a lot because he's the youngest
right and you know and so so she
obviously days like Lando doesn't know
landowners like that little one that's
the one I would eat first if they all
died right I think that we should grab a
laptop and we should Google and Sue for
right because our final answer Talan
Hansen what did my dog named me you know
what my answer at first was alpha but
now dang it do I have to agree with you
I want to make a united front here you
have swung me to say that our official
answer is that dogs know your name but
they don't call you by that name in
their own brain they what we were only
just saying that they smell they know
you by smell so it's just like they have
a language of smell so it's a smell name
that that doesn't use human vocal Larry
Kody you had googled Google I hope
you're not offended if I replace that if
you do that too many times your computer
will blow up okay
every time you google google my dog
creates a lot of problems what did my
dog name me question mark it's that
first one that comes up it's just a
funny meme I waste so much time calm I
have a Scientific American article now
first of all before you you give your
answer the answer that I now have is
that Talan Hansen didn't come up with
this question this is a mEEMIC question
that floats around the internet that we
cannot give to just talent hansen
because i mean it's got 19 comments and
1,057 awesome up votes on the amazing
website known as i waste so much time
which i'm sure you've been to i founded
that website but i do appreciate you
asking us Talan Talan
hey we're probably not even saying your
name right I said it three different
ways I bet you a dog could say this is
basically answering the question can
dogs speak it do they do they are they
actually talking and it just says
they're no they're just mimicking which
is what we already said well that's a
smokescreen answer maybe I should keep
googling this is when everybody clicks
away because I think it's how about this
how do dogs recognize their owners do
dogs name their owners you know you know
when in doubt go to the Denver Post you
get a mile up there you're gonna have
find all the answers gazing it faces is
how dogs pick out their owner
research shows dogs can read a lot from
a human's face according to recent
research for one thing they rely on
seeing a face to tell whether a person
is their guardian or a stranger and they
use the word guardian not owner okay I
got for pain Yin maybe they also read
emotional cues on a face the same way
people do with each other this is good
okay so according to a study published
in a recent issue of behavioral
behavioral processes scientists trained
a group of dogs to sit while in an MRI
machine and then individually recorded
their brain activity as they react the
sense of people and dogs who weren't
present these included a strange dog a
dog with whom they lived a strange
person and a person with whom they lived
excluding their owners since the owners
had to act as handlers while the dogs
were in them all right the dogs
exhibited greater brain activity for
familiar people than for any other scent
even familiar dogs not only do dogs
recognize and remember their human sense
but they also get more excited about a
whiff of their humans than about
anything else so the number one way that
in this article is is by scent and
they've identified you so basically
their name for you is a scent but also
they recognize your face by sight so the
user knows is to find and recognize
everything in the world including people
but it turns out that they're also very
good at using their eyes dogs evolved to
read human behavior and expressions as a
result of their canine ancestors who
received warm places to sleep around
human campfires by making people happy
to succeed at a survival strategy based
on making another species happy you need
to develop a knack for reading
expressions and body language and that's
just what dogs have done so in other
words again they're not they didn't
evolve to read each other's
body language they didn't need that they
had the sounds in this and the smells
and just the action
but they actually learned because of the
domestication to interact with us in LA
yeah according to dogs decoded on PBS
televisions program Nova dogs read human
emotion the same way humans do by
reading facial cues left to right like
humans huh I don't know what that means
left to right they don't do this with
other dogs and that's just one of the
show's interesting findings we read
emotions left or right just like we do
words ah yeah that seems odd to me well
that must be true though so what do we
what do we what have we learned here
we've learned that ferp anyons is a
potential substitute for pets and owners
and they can be used interchangeably yes
except if you have a hairless or a
skinless cat you're out of luck and you
have to come up with your own name and
don't send us pictures of either yeah
because they both sound really gross to
me we also determined that and everyone
will have to agree with the fact that
dogs you smell to identify all types of
stuff it's like they read a book with
their nose man so I think we're onto
something with that the name that your
dog has for you there's a smell is a
smell that cannot be named by humans but
it's probably something like yeah it's
like an alien it's like an alien trying
to it's like when those can see
different it sort of sort of talking to
each other and they bypass human
language and just went straight but
ironically for Jade that does sound like
it sounds very much like alpha so I was
right if they in both ways if it makes
you feel better if they if you want to
create your own truth that's fine
Anna Anna long as it doesn't impinge on
me I do we did not validate this last
point with the internet yet but who
cares we do also believe here at ear
biscuits that I lost my train of thought
oh good you don't need to be make any
statements of belief
here at ear biscuits believe what was
the last thing we figured out man that
dogs do know their owners names that's
it yeah we and ear biscuits
wholeheartedly believe that dogs do not
name their owners but do acknowledge
their owners names so to answer a
question Talon what did my dog name me
your dog didn't name you your parents
did and your dog recognizes that and
until your dog starts hanging out with
the wrong crowd of dolphins and starts
believing that it should be naming
itself you're in good hands
yeah stick the Gulf that should do it
for us it should i hope the music
playing
[Music]